[Music]
my son lee he went missing in 1988 on
september the 10th
my daughter claudia went missing eight
and a half years ago
when she was 35.
my brother's a missing person he's been
missing for 22 years
and that's why i joined the choir to
meet other families and have support
from the choir
the missing people choir is made up of
families with missing loved ones and
volunteers that want to sing with us
i sing my heart out for my boy
i can't talk to him
but i sing
i sing to him all the time when i'm
with the choir
connecting with other people that have
had a missing loved one is really
special and for me it was um 19 years
before i met anybody who is in the same
situation you know we know what each of
us has gone through and
we just connect with each other in a in
a very particular way
britain's got talent was an incredible a
juggernaut of an experience
[Music]
[Applause]
our win
wasn't going to be the big prize money
or a big single or anything like that it
was actually find someone that's what we
went out to achieve one young man even
came back because he saw his face on the
appeals and he'd been missing for six
weeks he was only a young boy and he
reconnected with his mother after
listening to us singing on bgt
where words
end
music carries on
and so when you apply it to
causes that really matter and that
resonate with people
you know it's extremely powerful stuff
and it's beautiful
daughter son brother
son son
[Music]
you